翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
みなさん こんにちは
明和電機代表取締役社長 土佐信道です
趣味は碁です
以後（囲碁）よろしくお願いします
（笑）
（拍手）
それでは製品説明に
移らさせていただきます
（観客の笑い声）
最初に 私が背負っているのは
『指パッチン木魚』といいます
指パッチンで木魚を鳴らす楽器ですね
100ボルトで動きます
えー 電源がないと動きません
（笑）
電気はどこにあるんですかね？
これかな？
あ これですね
（プラグを差し込む音）
それでは 演奏してみたいと思います
『指パッチン木魚』です
俺の心を聞いてくれ
（笑）
（歓声）
（指パッチン木魚の演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
（笑）（拍手）（歓声）
スタンディングオベーション
ありがとうございます
（笑）
続きましての製品はこちら
『オタマトーン』という楽器です
これはオタマジャクシの形をした
楽器なんですが
ここを押さえると音が出ます
（音）
口を開けると
音色が変わる
これを組み合わせると
曲が演奏できます
やってみます
（『今日の日はさようなら』の演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
こんな感じです
（拍手）
このように 明和電機はさまざまな
ナンセンスマシーンを作っています
（笑）
今日はそれについて
ご説明していきたいと思います
スライド お願いします
ナンセンスマシーンです
現在 23年間 明和電機をやっていますが
だいたい250種類くらいの
全く役に立たない機械を作り続けております
（笑）
ナンセンスマシーン
明和電機がいう ナンセンスというのは
無意味とか 非常識
という意味ではありません
「常識を超える」
という意味で使っております
すみません
この楽器 13キロあるんですね
（笑）
だんだん呼吸が
できなくなってきましたので
ちょっと下ろしたいと思います
（笑）
問題は１人で下ろせないということですね
はい 設計ミスでした
（笑）
常識を超えるという意味で使っています
さまざまな ナンセンスマシーンを
作り続けております
こういう機械を作る原動力 —
一番 なぜ僕がこういう
ナンセンスマシーンを
作ってるかと言いますと
根本にあるのは 自分に対する不可解
または世界に対する不可解です
解らない部分
それを知りたくて作っています
小さい頃から僕は
芸術家になりたかったので
自分の中に
不可解というものがあったんですが
それを取り出す方法として
最初はペインティング —
絵を描く方法しか知りませんでした
ただ 大学に入って 機械加工を学び
機械でこういう不可解を取り出す
芸術の方法を始めました
機械というのは 論理的な部品を
論理的に組み合わせないと動きません
つまり 理性の塊です
その理性の塊で不可解を
こう 締め上げていく
きゅっ きゅっとね —
そうやって作り上げたのが
ナンセンスマシーンです
もともと実は僕の父親が
明和電機という会社をやっておりましたので
小さい頃から工場で育ちましたので
その影響もあって この作り方に
落ち着いたんだと思います
ただ 不可解を理性で締め上げるのは
芸術家だけではありません
エンジニアの方
工学でも行います
例えば最初に飛んだ飛行機というのを
最初に見た人たちは
人間が空を飛ぶ訳がないので
みんな「ナンセンスだ」と思いました
常識を超えた機械 —
飛行機も最初はナンセンスマシーンでした
ところが現在 飛行機を見て
ナンセンスマシーンと みなさんは思いません
なぜかというと飛行機の仕組みを
みなさんは理解しましたし
それから 日常的に飛行機を
みなさん使われます
つまり普及したからです
アートで作るナンセンスマシーンと
工学で作るナンセンスマシーンは
ちょっと違います
出発点は同じなんですが
工学の場合は ―
エンジニアリングの場合は
不可解をできるだけ排除していきます
自然現象や人間の仕組みの中にある法則性を
そこから導き出して
それを人工物に落としていく
その過程で不可解は
どんどんどんどん削っていきます
ゼロにしていきます
ところが 芸術家の場合は
そうではありません
機械という理性の塊を使って
不可解の本質 —
居場所を探していくんですね
削って削って削って
どこに自分の中の不可解があるかを
この理性の塊の機械を使って
追い込んでいく
そういう作り方をしていきます
なので 芸術家が作った
ナンセンスマシーンには
どこかに不可解があります
それは人類にとって
永遠に解らないものだったりします
だから時代を超えて
芸術は人に感動を与えます
そうやって 僕もそれを目指して
ナンセンスマシーンを作っています
ここまでは 自分の内側の話 —
自分がものを作るという話だったんですが
芸術表現
またはクリエイティブに関して
大事なことは後半戦 —
それを見せるということです
ものを作ることと
ものを見せることは
同じぐらい重要です
そこにおいて明和電機は
２つのマスプロというのをやっています
「マスプロ」—
これは２つのマスプロの頭文字なんですが
１つが「マスプロダクション」
大量生産です
このオタマトーンも
実は大量生産で販売しております
みなさん 買ってください
（笑）
それからもう１つのマスプロは
「マスプロモーション」
たくさんの人に見せるということです
この２つの頭文字をとって
マスプロと呼んでいますが
明和電機は最初に考えたアートを
このマスプロによって広めています
マスプロダクション —
大量生産なんですが
これはおもちゃですが
それ以外に
いろんなマスプロダクションを
明和電機はやっています
頭文字を取って
「ABCDEFG計画」と呼んでるんですが
Aはアート Bはブック
CはCD つまり音楽ですね
それから DはDVD 映像です
Eはエキシビションやイベント
それから Fはファッション
この制服も売っています
ぜひ買ってください
（笑）
それからグッズのGですね
このように頭文字を取って
ABCDEFG —
さまざまな商品を作り
みなさまにお届けしています
それからマスプロモーションの方ですが
明和電機はこの楽器を使って
ライブをやっています
ミュージシャンというのは
自分が作った表現を
端から大衆に向かって
表現していきます
ところが 芸術家というのは
そうではないんですね
現在成功している芸術家の
みなさんがやっているのは
タブローと言われる一点物の作品を作り
それに高い価値を付けて
ハイカルチャー 富裕層に向けて
売ってゆくというのをやっています
ところが 明和電機はそうではなくて
アートをなんとか 大衆に売れないか？
大衆に届けられないか？
ということをやっています
これは非常にミュージシャンと
似ています
世界各地で自分が作った製品の
デモンストレーションの
ライブショーをやったり
展覧会などをやっております
このように明和電機の活動をまとめると
最初に行うのは自分の中にある不可解
それを機械を使って 理性を使って
ナンセンスマシーンを
作っていくということです
それが前半戦
それがアートです
しかし後半戦では
それをマスプロに落とし込んで
たくさんの人に伝えていく
伝えると何が 返っていくかというと
評価とお金です
このお金で次の製品をまた作る
というサイクルを続けています
こうやって 23年間
明和電機はさまざまな
ナンセンスマシーンを作り続けてきました
ご静聴どうもありがとうございます
（拍手）